[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cela
je n'y tiens tiens
meiway adjani
[Applaudissements]
je vous souhaite une soirée pleine de
bonheur et de fierté pour honorer ce
joyau si précieux à lui non pas quand le
césar du meilleur acteur dans un second
rôle est attribué à philippe katerine
dans le grand bain
c'est n'importe quoi bon ok peut dire
bien j'envoie ce césar à gilles
lellouche et use in à tiens j'ai c'est
un jour tu décides de faire le petit
bain je suis un gars
[Applaudissements]
césar de la meilleure actrice dans un
second rôle est attribué à karin viard
dans les chevilles
je suis super contente ça me fait
vraiment plaisir parce que je tenais
beaucoup à ce rôle
j'avais vraiment envie de faire partie
de cette histoire et ce rôle
épouvantable de mercy toxiques et qui
condamne sa fille une deuxième fois en
ne l'écoutent un pas en ne voulant pas
la croire
je trouvais ça terrible et j'avais envie
de le jouer pour pouvoir le dénoncer à
ma façon
waouh très émue pour apporter un gardois
laurent s'il vous plaît merci le césar
des publics est donc attribuée aux
touches 3
j'avais le docteur olivier baroux mais
juste remercier évidemment le public de
nous avons fait ce bon cadeau d'avoir
d'avoir été voir les tuche comme ça pas
loin de 6 millions d'entrées c'est
dingue 5 millions pour le 2 je vous dis
tout de suite on va faire le 4 pour
comme ça ça comme tout le monde on
commence à tourner en janvier
moi je voudrais surtout faire un petit
coucou à kad et olivier à la chaîne
comédie c'est là on s'est connus dans le
xviie arrondissement
vous avez beaucoup progressé depuis le
césar du meilleur acteur est attribué à
alex lutz donc
[Applaudissements]
alors deux minutes trente ensuite je
suis très impressionné et je n'avais par
superstition vraiment rien préparé
j'aimerais saluer tous mes camarades en
face parce que j'étais très fier d'être
dans cette sélection
pour mettre toutes les chances de mon
côté j'ai même eu la même coupe que
romain duris alors bon finalement voilà
on est une équipe et puis mon amour bon
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
sur laurent bonsoir gad un homme en slip
c'est c'est fragile c'est une légende
absolue du cinéma râler plus grands
acteurs de l'histoire
un réalisateur fantastique un producteur
visionnaire et un [ __ ] de beau gosse
au point de laisser le césar de la
meilleure réalisation est attribué à
jacques audiard je suis fier ça te fait
rire à chaque fois que je suis sur scène
salvadori
je suis un peu gêné vous avez fait des
films tellement extraordinaire je
remercie infiniment que je suis fille
trop intimidés permettre aux rescapés
je reste pour le césar du meilleur son
si ça vous dérange pas parce que comme
celle qui devait remettre meilleur
montage est morte à midi j'ai dit naples
et personne pour meilleurs sons il va y
passer aussi longs jours je le fais et
le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribuée à une amie léa drucker
[Applaudissements]
merci à al qaïda l'académie des césars
merci à tout le monde
j'aurais juste saluer toutes les toutes
les femmes toutes les féministes celles
qui écrivent agissent prennent la parole
et défendent au quotidien la cause des
femmes qui bravent parfois des tempêtes
d'insultés d'agressivité en tout genre
je voudrais les remercier parce qu'elles
m'ont permises en mai veillant d'être la
femme que je suis aujourd'hui merci
infiniment merci pour tout
[Musique]
césar du meilleur film est attribué à
jusqu'à la garde au toit laissant le
gardien
réalisé par xavier legrand wouah merci
merci pour ce cadeau magnifique jeu je
tiens à remercier bien sûr toute mon
équipe mes acteurs les à denis thomas
mon petit prince
mathilde au neveu alexandre dumas laisse
un message aujourd'hui où tu m'as dit
que j'avais changé d'avis mais tu peux
pas savoir à quel point tu as changé la
mienne et et merci tout simplement je
sais pas quoi vous dire merci
soirée musique
[Musique]
sur votre force et votre confiance et de
votre audace les gags et plusieurs
années de travail
vous êtes tous exceptionnels valérie
benguigui
je ne t'oublie pas merci fait des bons
films puissent continuerait de temps en
temps en faire plus merci infiniment
merci beaucoup
même sans poésie les rossignols se
mettrait à roter hand à tous un peu fous
de tout merci
[Applaudissements]